this week Starbucks decided that ending
racism should no longer be a core
product here's how the milk when seller
what if we were to write race together
on every Starbucks cup and that
facilitated a conversation between you
and our customers well you may be
laughed at relentlessly online to the
point your social media vice-president
is forced to delete their Twitter
account
nothing says openness and transparency
like blocking people who ask to have
questions but Starbucks is plan to
reverse centuries of inequality was so
much more than just writing a hashtag on
a cup so we're creating this partnership
with USA Today we've developed I think a
very important tool resource that will
be inserted into every us a paper
beginning on March 20th and I think it
can be a primary vehicle to get people
to understand that we need a new level
of sensitivity and understanding around
these issues
racism solved the problem with that
strategies that the majority of racists
can't read the initiative is all about
inclusiveness just take a look at the
poster for the campaign white hands were
also included this is about Starbucks
using their reach to start a
conversation
all over America they have stores
everywhere from Seattle Washington to
Ferguson Missouri there's no story in
Ferguson Missouri having a conversation
everywhere except there but Starbucks
has been avoiding discussing race since
its inception which is why they call a
long black in americano a short black in
espresso and a flat white a tasteless
dairy based profit Center for stupid
people the CEO Howard Schultz goes to
great pains to say that he doesn't want
his staff to solve any big problems he
just wants his staff to have a chat with
customers only if they want to now some
of you may be uncomfortable doing this
and if you are you have no mandate for
me to do it just bow out you don't have
to do it oh thank goodness
to many this is the disgusting
exploitation of contemporary anxiety to
get more people to buy your product
that's not your job Starbucks that's the
media's job your job is to sell hot
water and crush beans picked by
exploited workers in Africa
to keep us awake so we can exploit
contemporary anxiety to sell more
newspapers in your stores this grande
standing smacks of white guilt probably
down to the fact that despite 40% of
Starbucks employees being non-white of
the 19 Starbucks executives only three a
non-white this is probably a case of the
latte calling the cafe only white but
now due to pressure on social media
instead of leaning in Starbucks is
backing the cup quickly and dropping the
whole campaign so now a guess ending
racism is up to me so grab a pen and a
cup and take some notes who are shoulder
no I'm manager of this store I'm
wondering what you're doing oh I'm just
starting a conversation about rice okay
um you don't work here you can't
actually do that here I'm not working
here I'm just standing I'm gonna get I
don't want you doing that well we're
just starting a conversation about race
where we talk to you about race life at
Starbucks we think racism is a bit of a
grande problem so we're trying to make
it more of a toll problem are you
interested in helping Starbucks make it
at all problem sure what's your favorite
race my favorite racing we're Hispanic
so we'll go from Hispanic the human race
I think everybody is my favorite
American suppose I say the marathon
and started over in Greece so that's it
do you think HBO's girls was to what I
think they need an easy guy like me on
the show for sure they'll be funny
how many shots are in the Ferguson
espresso to eventually six yeah yeah six
firmly for more than needed how do you
think Starbucks can fix racism maybe
they could just serve african-american
okay have you tried our new flat white
privilege no I have it it's great it's
not served in the cup and served in a
smuggler Wow you try it yeah you I'm
gonna I'm gonna pull out some race-based
conversation starters alright and I want
you to pick one that you like that you
have a childhood friend of a different
race that you lost touch with why that's
a good one
I go in there I tell them that before we
do it out yeah alrighty the follow me
guys so Kevin enters the Starbucks
coffee shop armed with a Starbucks
talking point but will he end racism
forever question first did you have a
childhood friend of a different race
that you've lost touch with and why ok
and in 20 different schools and haven't
talked to him since
oh you too wow what race was he or you
know I don't know you don't know he was
like a Mexican agent mix oh cool and
you're yourself um let your mind up a
nice Spanish Irish dude right on right
on
and he did it Kevin and racism so keV
how was that to be honest the barista
was really nice and he asked him really
questionable maybe this thing works it's
like that Michael Jackson song black or
white it's actually how I prefer my
coffee black or white it doesn't matter
if my coffee is like
Wow watching Kevin made me realize that
maybe Starbucks was right maybe they
went through the grinder for nothing
maybe this campaign actually does work
and maybe we are the ones that need to
race together together
you